Today is my husband's in my 11th anniversary.
It's been seven years that he's avoided store bought Nutella
because of the less than satisfactory ingredients,
so that's exactly what I'm surprising him with.
While my hazelnuts roasted for 10 minutes in the oven,
I cleaned one of my cutting boards with my non toxic concentrate
and oxy from Branch Basics.
While that penetrated the moldy wood,
I continued on to my homemade Nutella
by rubbing the spoons off of the roasted hazelnuts.
Although slightly tedious,
this process didn't take long.
With a food processor, I process the nuts into a hazelnut butter
and then added the remaining ingredients.
Nutella has 22 grams of refined sugar for just 2 tablespoons.
And it's got GMO soy, too,
which is why I'm making mine with just a small amount of maple sugar
and free of Gmos and glyphosate.
After scrubbing my cutting board,
I was truly shocked by how clean it became,
especially since I'd considered throwing it out
after firming up in the pantry.
The homemade Nutella was not only scoop worthy,
it was also husband approved.